wanna play some not damn phone Oh
seriously dude yeah seriously yeah I'm
just so pumped about this game I know
but when you show your real self people
will say you're being fake so oh sorry
let me turn and people that go to see a
reaction video are gonna be like hey
you're being fake because you're so
enthused about it
okay go ahead and do the studio intro
I'll be serious people want is very
subtle and bland
hello I'm Ryan right I'm Dan severed
fallout for launch trailer we're really
excited about it really excited there's
blood blood and core yeah dense violence
strong language I thought they use the
word [ __ ] use of drugs whoo I'm really
hoping for a little kindness Z ooh
I mean I'm sorry too excited how
unfortunate I could golden
everything can change in an instant
whether or not you're ready
this wasn't the world I wanted but it
was the one I found myself in so yeah
they just accept that and stop this to
get ready because I know war no more -
well I never changes
I have a question the only question that
matters how big is it would you risk
your life for your fellow man
even if that man is a simple one beneath
the company there is a kid's known as
the Institute
a malignant growth that needs to be cut
before it infects the surface they're
the real enemy not the rapes not the
super mutants
even those tools over in
I'm not a sin for God's sake for family
this is ridiculous so truth
grounders gameplay dude oh [ __ ] holy
Shah
protect the people at a minutes notice
and decide our own future
I'm out of time
this campaign will be costly
for in the end we will be saving human
cotton from its worst enemy itself
so where is it this Institute how do I
get there
and you've been paying attention you
don't find the Institute
Institute finds you
seriously why they get the Gatorade sign
it really bothers me I'm a little mad at
you know it really bothers me good I
hope I didn't upset all you fallout fans
oh my god yes I want it I've never
played fallout I want it but I know
Dan's a fan it looks so God so I brought
down here today to talk about fallout 4
for you guys so let me just write it the
hate on me for not knowing let's just
break it down if you have a console or
when I don't I don't remember if the PC
is dropping it yeah I think the PC
version is dropping say but it doesn't
matter you buy it
I'm porous buck and I can't do it right
now but you bite they showed off a lot
of new guns or they well maybe not a
whole lot of new guns there was the nuke
launcher they showed off some violence
they showed off some guns they showed
off to new characters the lip-syncing
was a little off whatever I forgot I was
watching a game trailer I was really
pulled into what was going on in this
world that I was like thinking of that
this was a movie and I was getting
excited for it then I realized though I
got to figure out how to do all this I
yeah yeah I do think out of everything
that I've seen so far for fallout 4 this
one has a little bit more story attached
to a sexiness there was a there was a
lot more booty for you in this one that
girl's ass at the end I'm not gonna lie
it was good he was really good
god I would anal pleasure her so much
okay well about I'm telling I'm talking
DP anal that's two penises in one but
it's really want to watch a video no
don't don't
you sure no you don't want to see it I'm
sure it would be a funny reaction I'm
sure the woman fans would appreciate it
I'm not I'm not watching that huh
no what you afraid you're getting it
turned on up is afraid to you Dan I was
afraid to you gotta just accept
man you gotta just accept it me never
wanna do that with Melissa and they're
like zombie creatures in there yeah the
mutants I knew that from never playing
the game mm-hmm
that was cool I like I like a good
zombie vibe to anything I really frickin
enjoy watching that helicopter getting
blown up so it always feels like
whenever we get to a launch trailer it's
always the best and brings the most hype
I mean Greta it's like crunch time they
need to sell some [ __ ] games right
now I mean this comes out I don't know
probably on the release of this video or
like the dick next day and this thing is
this is gonna set records I I have a
good feeling about it everything that
we've seen about it the game looks great
it's got all of the familiar combat from
fallout 4 that we saw in fallout 3 and
new Vegas and all well not the second
the first one those are totally
different but um it's just everything
about it is just it's making of a really
good game and now it's just a matter of
like is it going to function day one and
I hate I hate that I have to say that
about any game these days but it's it's
got to be set because it's their big
games their big files Ryan is just gonna
imitate what I do is that close and you
do that for me thank you uh it's like
there if there's so much work that goes
into this and they're so big that
mistakes are gonna get through and it's
just a matter if it is they're gonna be
great like game breaking glitches on day
one it might not and if it runs smooth
is held that just makes this game even
better I'm sorry those kids outside we
asked them to be quiet and now they're
making a lot of noise let's hope they
don't fall out of the balcony
I appreciate the pun but it don't
appreciate the chopper you will in one
minute anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel if you need to it you can
subscribe today and become a rejecter
bot and you can check out Dan's gaming
channel it's right here it's right here
it's right here the ok camera I check
the camera buttons right
yeah later [ __ ] jerk Malik cleanse up
hi Ryan
my name is Malik clay and I'm an
animator and story writer I've been
working on my own original anime series
called heatwave the reason I need a
shout out is that since its original and
unprofessional no one gives it a fair
chance well the fact that it's
unprofessional whenever you don't ever
want to say that to someone because who
wants to watch anything that's really
unprofessional my shits unprofessional I
don't say it's unprofessional though
because someone's gonna want to watch it
yeah I mean definitely say your shit's
unprofessional just say it's like you
know it's the start of something awesome
yeah give it a fair chance of real
rejects or awesome stay blessed and I
left a feature in an episode malee clay
I would love to be in an episode of your
anime series I think I could play like
the the crazy old grandpa you know you
would play the best crazy old brand he'd
be like kind of a pervert oh you totally
feel like he's always hitting on the
nurse and stuff but your boob gets an
erection freaks them out overdoses on
viagra that's gonna hate yeah exactly
it's like you get a really creepy vibe
from him but you're like a kid show for
some reason yeah yeah but like in the
end you know it's it's still grandpa
he's got good wisdom and can shoot
energy beams from his eyes everyone this
anime series is called heatwave find
Malik clay and tell him I wish to be on
it mm-hmm do it click this button my
dance penis I hate my life